when you think of the biggest most
money-making merchandised and
capitalized game series of all time
there's only one franchise that comes to
mind pokemon for the entirety of its
lifespan pokemon has been a financial
powerhouse and every year the series
seems to grow in popularity and revenue
whether it's games cards a show toys or
even pokemon branded clothes that you
need you'll have no difficulty finding a
product that appeals to you
everyone knows pikachu's face and nearly
every child born within the past 20
years has had a first-hand experience
with pokemon it is in some respects
inescapable if you hate pokemon too bad
because this little electric mouse runs
the world and you'll just have to sit
back and deal with it one could even say
that pokemon is uncontainable which
poses quite the issue for the scp
foundation who worked tirelessly to
ensure that no facet of life is withheld
from its reach but the foundation rarely
deals with major franchises beloved by
millions upon millions of people across
the world and for a good reason too an
anomaly tied in with a major franchise
poses a lot of problems on the
containment side namely its ability to
spread uncontrollably and without care
being witnessed by countless individuals
before the foundation comes up with a
way to contain it global supply lines
have to be interrupted to prevent
anomalous products from hitting shelves
corporate espionage committed and most
of all a massively expensive cover-up
operation to remove said products from
consumers hands if the foundation had to
deal with an anomaly affecting the
pokemon franchise there's no telling how
out of hand it would get before they'd
be able to get a handle on the situation
but in 2019 that's exactly what happened
today we're going to be looking at
scp-5254
an anomaly dubbed gotta catch em all in
the foundations database the year was
2019 the place japan the home country of
the pokemon franchise every year since
2014 the pokemon company has held a
festival named pikachu outbreak in the
city of yokohama in which hundreds of
costumed actors dressed as pikachu would
crowd the city's mirai district and
perform dance and even participate in a
parade the event was intended to
celebrate the pokemon franchise and
promote whatever the latest venture the
series is pushing whether it's a game a
movie or something else the festival
proved to be successful and has been
held every year since after all who
wouldn't want to see a legion of pikachu
running amok through the streets but the
fun would be short-lived during the 2019
outbreak where something incredibly
unusual occurred picture this a large
crowd hundreds of fans dressed in
pokemon themed attire standing on both
sides of the streets men women children
anyone and everyone came to see the
pikachu outbreak and they weren't
disappointed parading down the street
was a horde of pikachu just as
advertised they danced bounced and
walked together in routine fashion all
while the crowd cheered and yelled even
the spectators in the crowd showed their
spirit with pikachu-themed hats yellow
tails fastened to their backs and yellow
face masks with two electrified red
circles on the cheeks the parade
proceeded as normal that is until one of
the parading pikachu started behaving
oddly it began as out of sync movements
strange wobbles and deviations from the
parade path for the heavily coordinated
outbreak festival this was unusual the
rest of the pikachu line danced to the
beat of the music sticking in formation
as best as they could then as if pushed
by an invisible force the strange
pikachu raced forward diving headfirst
into the crowd barreling into the group
of people and eventually colliding the
crowd moved out of the way slightly
shocked no pun intended by what had
occurred but then it happened again two
more pikachu ran into the crowd and then
again over 15 pikachu ran themselves
into the crowd resulting in a massive
disruption of the parade and the
shutdown of the event entirely the
foundation quickly caught wind of this
and sent their closest operatives to
assess the situation in a controlled
fashion after blocking off the crowd and
shutting down the event another strange
detail emerged one that ensured the
foundation that there had been some sort
of anomalous significance to what was
occurring here some of the crowd members
involved in the collisions were
suffering very peculiar medical injuries
namely blunt force trauma way stronger
than what a clash with a costumed actor
would induce and severe electrical burns
the foundation was positive there was
something occurring here and with
as vast and popular as pokemon they
didn't want to take any chances
immediately foundation agents began
collecting information on the event
setting up probes in the offices of game
freak and the pokemon company and
attempting to get to the bottom of what
exactly happened during the parade when
the foundation interrogated the 15
mascots who collided with the crowd they
were shocked to learn that they weren't
mascots at all but instead fully
separate entities that resembled the
pikachu costume x-rays revealed that
their once human skeletons were now
fused to their costumes and touching
them produced a minor electric shock the
performers had become pikachu and now
they were unable to be removed from
their costumes every captured instance
had expired before the foundation was
able to fully study and discern what was
occurring to them their bodies unable to
support themselves after such a lethal
extreme transformation later observation
found that the synthetic components of
the costumes such as the cotton and
plastic composites had fused into their
flesh and muscle tissue bodily fluids
were found to contain foreign dna and
numerous strange structures to the point
where an ordinary human's genetic makeup
would be incomparable and unrecognizable
with that affected by the anomaly the
foundation tentatively opened a file on
scp-5254
the anomalous transformation of a human
into the rough approximation of a
pokemon character and began carrying out
tests to determine what occurred during
the festival what caused
scp-5254 to manifest it couldn't have
been random could it the foundation
needed to know one theory that the
researchers working on the
scp-5254 file had come up with was that
it was the large gathering of pokemon
related clothing worn by the crowd that
prompted the transformation but that
begged the question why hadn't this
occurred at any previous festivals or
large pokemon related gatherings it was
a huge franchise there were absolutely
more events that had masses of costume
fans donning pokemon related gear did
something happen in recent years to
manifest this anomaly the only way to
find out was to conduct testing in one
of the easier experiments that a d-class
personnel was tasked with carrying out
the foundation ordered a group of them
to dress entirely in pokemon-related
clothing which the foundation provided
themselves some items such as a
full-bodied gardevoir onesie were taken
from dr kleff's personal collection
itself no he is not taking further
questions anyways with the d-class
looking utterly ridiculous and full
pokemon getup the observing researchers
began their tests first was a d-class
outfitted solely in a pokemon pikachu
big face with ears hat as the product's
official title stated after standing
there for 15 minutes the foundation
determined that there was no discernible
effect next was a pokemon detective
pikachu cosplaying mask latex which the
foundation placed on the same d-class
after another 15 minutes with no changes
observed the d-class closed the
experiment remarking that it was stupid
the research team told the d-class to
remain composed and to just continue
along with the trials unless they wanted
to be reprimanded after that was a debun
adult onesie pikachu animal pajamas a
few researchers held back laughter as
the hardened muscular d-class in front
of them stood around in a pikachu onesie
that barely fit him after asking him how
he was feeling the subject quickly
turned aggressive the results from this
test were deemed inconclusive due to
researchers being unable to determine if
the quick snap in anger was as a result
of a potential anomaly or whether the
d-class was just getting fed up with
having to do this in my opinion this
test was hilarious for the next test two
d-classes were brought in clad in
pikachu onesies the d-class were placed
four meters apart after a period of time
a tingling sensation was reported in the
arms and legs akin to that pins and
needles feeling you get when your arms
fall asleep or when you get shocked by
static electricity the next one had four
d-classes all dressed similar to the
previous group instead of being meters
apart they were asked to hold hands
which the d-classes begrudgingly did
severe migraines were reported as well
as throbbing pain in the cranium and
lower jaws of the face near the tailbone
some d-classes reported a dull aching
most curiously several areas on their
body had begun to change in skin
coloration namely a mustard yellow
eventually the foundation began to test
for an affiliation or emotional
connection to the pokemon franchise
could that be the key to understanding
scp-5254
another 4d class all noted pokemon fans
were brought in one had owned a copy of
pokemon yellow for the game boy when he
was a child and another had a
high-leveled account on the pokemon go
app the foundation discovered that these
d-class reported muscle spasms along the
extent of their spines with one
complaining of tightness in their chest
before coughing up tufts of fur and
another physically recoiling upon an
attempt at physical contact in fear they
would electrically shock the researcher
these experiments proved to be fruitful
for the foundation as they learned that
scp-5254 was irreversible removing the
clothing or items did not result in the
transformative properties of
scp-5254 reversing furthermore the
testing went on beyond this point just
to cover all possible bases of what
scp-5254 was before the details were
properly ironed out a total of 56
d-class personnel were lost during these
experiments and testing paused due to
concern by foundation higher-ups of a
potential security breach and damage
being done to the site's power grid but
most importantly a connection to the
pokemon brand was what enabled scp-5254
to truly take effect that's what
occurred at the outbreak festival with
the bodies of costumed pikachu fanatics
fused into their costumes and barreled
towards the crowd now that the
foundation understood the how of
scp-5254 they still had to get to the
why even by foundation standards this is
a pretty odd and random anomaly did the
answers lie with game freak or the
pokemon company itself after the
festival incident the foundation put web
probes into the servers of the pokemon
company's japanese branch and had their
web crawlers scan through millions of
correspondence emails to find any hint
of unusual behavior a series of emails
between major shareholders in the
company were found the first was from
kimishima tatsumi the ceo of nintendo
the overseeing company above the pokemon
company and sunikazu ishihara the
latter's ceo do not ask questions if
this sir viper wants manpower for his
project give it to him our society will
not mess with these irrelevant
individuals he whoever he claims to be
may be charging us a small fortune but
at least he seems genuinely interested
in bringing our creations to life
bringing their creations to life how
curious the email was dated to 2017 two
years before the outbreak incident the
foundation decided to dig deeper another
email from 2017 exchanged between the
two individuals months after the first
tuesday will mark the fifth visit by the
fukushima orphanage to our headquarters
i told the press it's part of our global
outreach program to spread the joy of
pokemon to the rest of the world early
results have been positive i should have
a specimen to show you the next time we
meet in tokyo your daughter likes evie
yes it seemed like these executives were
talking about creating real pokemon
somehow what did the orphanage have to
do with this another email read play
anytime anywhere with anyone yes the
slogan for the switch is very apt for
what we're trying to accomplish your
marketing team deserves a raise i am
pleased to report pokemon go has its 750
million unique downloads in july and 5
million daily average users this past
week the popularity of the franchise
continues to grow think of the
possibilities once we integrate
augmented reality ar technology into the
project alteria as a clean and efficient
form of air transportation charizard
serving in the self-defense forces and
yes pikachu making our reliance on
nuclear energy a thing of the past soon
pokemon will come to life before our
very eyes the foundation couldn't
believe something as absurd as creating
real pokemon was a genuine possibility
for these companies it was going on
right beneath their noses but the emails
from 2018 began to show cracks in the
pokemon company and nintendo's plans the
accidents are growing in number are you
sure sir viper has everything under
control we cannot hide these incidents
from the public forever we already have
our hands full trying to catch the
runaways if we don't take action soon
more people will get hurt or worse the
pokemon brand will be tarnished forever
whoever was responsible for creating
pokemon for the companies was going by
the alias of sir viper and it seemed
like their experiments weren't working
the way they planned an email directly
addressed to surviper fully encapsulated
the pokemon company's disgust at the
individual once they realized the
experiments weren't succeeding in
creating an immersive fun pokemon
experience in the real world you
promised us pokemon as pets and
companions not these mutations i've had
to recall thousands of faulty
merchandise with tens of thousands of
defective products still circulating the
market just what kind of sorcery have
you forced upon our hands the government
is breathing down my neck tatsumi-san
has had to resign and i'm starting to
hear about this foundation poking around
tell me the truth is there any way to
reverse the effects or have you doomed
us all survivor 1995 as their screen
name read responded with this i don't
know what to tell you i've given the
people what they want only true fans
will get a pokemon of their own your
company was the very best at building
your brand congratulations today pokemon
has taken over our hearts and minds
perhaps one day we will see them take
over the world and with that the company
had cut off all communication with sir
viper but now the foundation had to get
to the bottom of what was happening in
these board rooms and offices making
pokemon in real life it sounded crazy
and from the way the emails were worded
they had apparently succeeded in making
something even if they considered it a
failure three months later after all of
the research on
scp-5254 was conducted the overseer
council authorized a raid on the pokemon
company offices in monado city tokyo on
june 16 2019 from the way the emails
were written they had reason to believe
that civilians were potentially being
held against their will and used in
these experiments failure to deal with
them now could potentially spell
disaster if they got out and the cause
of
scp-5254 wasn't immediately neutralized
following the japanese government's
authorization of the raid a foundation
mobile task force detachment from
epsilon 11 nine-tailed fox was stationed
outside the offices the task force broke
into the building through the fire exit
and promptly cleared out tourists and
civilians from the area during the raid
they encountered a large creature that
resembled the charizard an orange
fire-breathing dragon pokemon that
stopped them in their tracks in the
hallway wings and elongated snout the
perfect color it looked exactly as if a
charizard had left from the screen and
into real life it spewed combustible
orange liquid at the team but they
quickly dispatched it with ease using
their weapons to put some water on the
pokemon's fire well the water was
actually a salvo of bullets but the
metaphor still works most of the
building was cleared and those inside
detained for further questioning but
then the team came to a set of steel
doors inside was a room littered with
toys brightly colored walls and large
metal cages inside the cages were some
of the most disgusting creations the
team had ever witnessed sir vipers
failed experiments clearly entities at
various stages of
scp-5254 transformation one resembled a
vulpix a fox pokemon it had engorged eye
sockets and blood flowing down their
cheeks another cage had a boy with
cheekbones protruding high and sideways
pulling thin skin over the rest of his
face another had a large bear-like
entity with serrated claws with
alternate fingers peeling and
decomposing underneath most horrifying
of all were a pair inside cages near the
other side of the room a girl with an
extended flattened engorged tongue which
pulled drool onto the floor at her feet
she was made to resemble a lick tongue a
pokemon with a similarly large tongue
another was an elongated purple snake
like the pokemon arbok except its head
was that of a toddler it rised back and
forth bawling and screaming the team
requested immediate medical pickup to
remove the specimens from the room
wherever sir viper the individual
responsible for this was the foundation
could not locate them the foundation
contained the experiments and detained
mr ishihara the ceo of the company who
was brought back to the research site
for an interview ishihara claimed not to
know of the experiment's existence but
he quickly broke down when asked about
sir viper ishihara had this to say we
didn't ask too many questions when we
found out what he had been doing to the
children we terminated his contract
immediately but the damage had been done
later we discovered he had already
tampered with our production lines and
distribution infrastructure at this
point it's impossible to tell which
products had been affected on the market
following this global coordination
between nintendo the foundation and the
pokemon company in an attempt to figure
out a solution to products that were
affected by scp-5254
is presently ongoing all attempts to
contact server 1995's email result in
the same automated message happy hunting
but even you can't catch them all
now go watch
scp-3108 the nerfing gun and scp-387 the
living lego for more kid-friendly
franchises twisted into anomalous
entities contained by the scp foundation